the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money my name is anthony
o'neill host of the popular youtube show
and podcast show the table with anthony
o'neal and co-hosting with me today
is number one national bestselling
author and host of the christy wright
show
the one and only christy wright and
together we'll be answering your
questions taking your phone calls
if you have a question about your life
about your money or if you're a young
person you want to start a business or
if you're a lady
and you just want to learn how to get
balanced how to go after your purpose
um give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five again the number
here
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five we have
a couple phone lines open but keep
calling and we'll get you through and
we'll love to have a conversation with
you
about your life about your money um and
kristy what all are you talking about
because every time i get on the show
with you i'll be saying chrissy's this
chrissy that
what's your sweet spot kristen you know
it's interesting because you've kind of
watched this transition over the last
couple years but for five years i helped
women start businesses that's certainly
still something i love to do yeah we
have the business boutique event i have
my book all that stuff is still
there helping people but in the last
year or so maybe two years i've really
felt god kind of urging me
into this new space to not help women
with just businesses but to help them in
their
lives in the area of personal
development and even specifically
faith and then what's cool anthony is is
while i felt god leading me in this
space
you start to see the market kind of
going in that direction too we'd have
you know women come to the event women
come to the listen to the business
boutique podcast or read my book and i
would always say oh
you know what's your business yeah and
they would say oh i don't have a
business you just help me reach my goals
wow or you help me in my relationship
with my spouse or you help me push past
my fear to apply for this job and
um so one of the things that i really
want to do and you and i are big
vision people we love helping people
have vision we have vision for ourselves
but i think there's a gap in the market
between faith and personal development
and people tend to think they're
mutually exclusive and they're not
you need both you need to have a faith
and i believe god can
lead you and has plans for you and you
need to work really hard and have goals
and follow steps and
be smart with what you have and so i
want to help people do that i want to
help people have a bigger faith
and a better life and bridge that gap
between faith and personal development
that's what i'm doing so it's been fun
man every tuesday you guys you can check
her out on youtube or anywhere you
listen to podcasts
uh break through what's holding you back
create a life you're proud of and build
confidence in yourself
and the god who created you every
tuesday on youtube
this is christy wright check her out so
triple eight eight two five
five two two five give us a call right
now we have uh
josh with us in charlotte north carolina
good afternoon josh how can christy and
i help
afternoon guys how are y'all going good
um so me and my wife are
in a position where we are probably
going to want to refinance just what's
the way our market is right now
the big thing that we are having concern
about is
i run a small business that is growing
income
that is i use one of our spare bedrooms
for now we want to have a second child
um and we don't have another bedroom
that's available so one of the things
that we considered is when we go to
refinance
seeing if it would actually be worth it
to
try to expand onto the house and add an
extra place so i can actually run my
business from that and have a place for
our future children
um so and i have no information on how
to
go about that or if it would even be
worth it to do so and if i do what way
to go about it
okay so you're pretty much refinancing
not to go down to a 15-year fixed-rate
loan
you're pretty much refinancing so you
can do some home uh renovations am i
correct
um that's the big thing we want to
refinance anyway because we got in one
of those bad situations where
uh because we couldn't put 20 percent
down on the home we had to have a
mortgage insurance which does nothing
for us
so we're losing about 30. yeah we're
losing about 1300 a month
or 1300 a year anyway
just from that so we want to try to
refinance just to get that off if
anything else but do you have 20 percent
equity in the house
do you have 20 more
our loan we did at our balance is 150
but they are estimating the value of the
house currently to be about 230 to 240.
okay all right so you will have more
than 20 equity in the house if the house
values at that price
and so i like that so a refined so you
can get rid of your pmi will be a good
option
i would recommend you check out
churchill mortgage for that uh when you
refi
no i'm not going to say take out money
to add on to your house
if you're going to do that you're going
to do that cash okay
um i don't want you to take out money to
put back into the home no i want you to
take out
refi so you can get a better interest
rate get out of the pmi
and then i want you to cash flow any
renovations that you want to do to the
house
but before we talk about renovations uh
josh do you have any other kind of debt
right now
we do have a little bit of debt uh we
have
a about a four thousand dollar medical
bill and then
uh we were debt free up until the house
was purchased but then we had some
a credit card that got away and it's
about 3 500 so we have about
7 500 in debt right now okay so we're 7
500
in debt do you have any money in the
bank
i do we've got 2 000 an emergency fund
and then uh we've got some
a couple thousand in other things that
we're just trying to make sure taxes go
through
okay okay we could probably throw that
at something if we need to so here
here's here's what i'm thinking chrissy
uh you know
is one we do refi so we can get rid of
the pmi because that will free up
thirteen hundred dollars right there in
income
okay and then from there it's josh i
want you to pay off this 7 500
okay i want you to take a thousand
dollars out of that go ahead and put
that towards the 7 500
in debt get out of this get you a fully
funded emergency fund up
and then from there because this listen
to what you just said
what you said was i took i got a
mortgage we were debt free then when we
got the mortgage we had to go back into
that because we needed to do some stuff
around the house
so we want to prevent this from
happening again and so
go ahead get out of debt get a fully
funded emergency fund up
follow the baby subs and then from there
cash flow any renovations that you may
need yeah and i would say the one thing
i would add
in relation to the business expense
would be to
find all the options you have are there
co-working spaces those are somewhere
you can sublease is there something
that's a
lower cost where you can have that room
for your baby have that room for your
family that's growing
without taking on this extra expense in
your home this extra loan like anthony's
talking about
if you get really scrappy and get really
creative you will come up with a lot
more options right now this is just the
easiest most visible option for you you
have a lot more options you can run your
business
a lot of different ways i'm guessing so
i want to challenge you to make a list
of what are all the different ways that
you can find space for your business if
and when your family grows
to not feel like that you're painted in
a corner there that was so good chrissy
i like that and here's the thing you
guys
we're never going to tell you to deviate
off of the baby steps the baby steps
work
the baby steps got me out of debt
they've helped christy they've helped
all of us here so we're going to go
right in line with the baby steps and so
the key thing here to remember
for those of you all listening right now
is when you get a mortgage we're never
going to tell you to refi so you could
do things to the house
no we're going to tell you to refi so
you can pay off the house
sooner quicker faster anything when it
comes to
adding on to the house fixing up the
house we are always we will always tell
you to re
not refi we would tell you to cash flow
that
because we want you to pay off the house
we want you to build equity we want you
to build wealth
the number one thing that we found in
our millionaire study was that most of
these millionaires had a paid
off mortgage and that is important
america to remember
make sure that we have a paid off
mortgage so we can start building wealth
start build building legacy this is
chrissy wright this is anthony o'neil
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsay to find out more
[Applause]
[Applause]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five my name
is anthony o'neil and joining with me
today is chrissy wright
and we're here to take your phone calls
answer your questions talk about life
talk about purpose talk about money
talk about careers talk about all things
around life uh we had a phone line just
opened up so give us a call triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
chase is with us in st
louis uh good afternoon chase how can
christy and i help
hey guys thanks for having me on the
show oh no problem at all man how can we
help bro
so i'm uh i'm a second
semester junior so i've just i'm about
to finish my junior year of college okay
um i just transferred to my four-year
university after attending community
college in the past
okay up until this up until this point
i've paid for all my tuition out of
pocket by myself awesome
um because my goal is just to graduate
debt free
so i took that a subsidized student loan
of 5500
my plan for the next two semesters of
college is to
pay the last two semesters out of pocket
like i did in the past
but i'm starting to rethink that idea
as federal student loan forgiveness is
kind of a discussion in politics
do you guys think i should get two more
um
loans to cover the rent of my school or
should i just
pay for as much as i can out of pocket
chase let me ask you this question man
you sound like a very bright smart
young man have you done any research
around these forgiveness programs
um not completely
okay let me let me help you out because
i want to make sure that you know
i don't want to give you an opinion i
want to give you facts okay
the facts are showing that only one
percent of the people
who actually apply for the student loan
forgiveness program
um are getting approved so that's 99
of the people right now are not getting
approved
so let me ask you a question with
knowing that
fact right there as a young man in your
shoes do you want to rely
on them to forgive you
no exactly i probably should not
exactly who's the best person you can
rely on
definitely myself there you go there you
go young man that's
it right there here's the thing um to
answer the question uh directly
and i'm pretty sure christy will agree
with me no you should not rely on
someone else you should not rely on the
government you should not rely on the
white house
you should not rely on congress to take
care of your house bro
you've worked hard to stay out of debt
continue working hard
to stay out of debt continue working
hard to take control over
your life and i promise you when you
turn 30 years old when you turn 35 you
have a wife you have kids
you're going to say thank you to your
younger self because you put in the work
and you avoided that at
all costs okay it's gonna be hard i'm
not gonna sit here and play with you
it's gonna be hard
it's gonna be frustrating there's gonna
be some days you feel like giving in on
these last two semesters
but when you walk across that stage
brother and i hope america you all are
listening to me
when you walk across that stage with a
debt-free degree
and when you get around your friends and
they're talking about the college
experience
and they're over here crying and whining
because they have fifty thousand
a hundred thousand dollars in student
loan debt and you're like i have nothing
you're gonna feel like superman you're
gonna feel like man it was
worth it so do not give in to because of
the talks right now no stay true to your
path
stay true to who you are and graduate
100
debt free and our brother i'm telling
you right now you do that
you're setting yourself up to be a
millionaire here's the thing to chase
that's so
cool number one you've already done it
you're really really close
you've already done this you've already
cash flowed your college up to this
point which is incredible and unlike the
vast majority
of college students so you have this
skill you have the confidence you've
done it before
you know you can do it again and finish
this out but i want to unpack something
for you really quickly and this is for
all of you listening
about any type of debt what i want help
people to understand anthony is that
when we talk about debt we're not just
talking about the financial aspect of it
this is not just a numbers game yes you
pay more
when you take on debt and you have
interest there's the financial
implication
but there's a power and control element
chase we want you to have all the power
yes all the control
when you sign your life away when you
sign your future away when you sign your
finances away you're giving
up those things you're giving up power
you're giving up control not just the
finances
and so we want you to keep all the power
keep all the control keep the risk low
and when you stay out of debt
you do that no one can tell you what to
do because it's your money
and your future and i want people to
understand that anthony because
sometimes they think it's just a
financial thing like
i don't mind the payment of 50 a month
well i don't mind the interest of x
hundred dollars it's like no no
you're giving up power right you're
giving up control
and you're right to your decision making
in your future and man that to me
is more motivating than the money side
of it because i'm like i don't want
anybody to be the boss of me i don't
want anybody to
to be able to tell me what i can and
can't do in my future you know what
chrissy you
you teaching good you know one of the
things i talk about on my show over at
the table
uh with anthony o'neill on youtube is uh
i was just the other week with me one of
my good friends
leo he said something that was so good
and something that i teach as well he
says every
dime you give into interest which is the
penalty for debt
is one dime you're taking away from you
and your family to build wealth
so not only are you giving up power but
you're also giving up the opportunity to
build
wealth you know um he said just in his
student loans alone
if he just would have paid the minimum
payment on the student loans
he was going to pay 125 thousand dollars
in
interest i believe it uh
125 000 in the interest
that's not going towards his debt that's
not going towards building wealth that's
going towards someone else
that's robbery yeah and so this is why
i'm so passionate about this message
especially young people you know all
peoples um
really but when i hear young people say
i want to take out the student loans and
get it forgiven no no no no stay awake
work hard so you can build true wealth
at a younger age well the reason i bring
up this power control element not just
of the debt but in in relation to
chase's question with loan forgiveness
if you say i hope i think
i'm gonna cross my fingers a wish and a
prayer that they're gonna forgive me
and then they don't because they
probably won't again you've given up
your power
you've given up your control for a wish
and a prayer that didn't work out
instead we want you to follow a proven
plan
that has no risk it's not a wish and a
prayer it works and it's proven
and then you're going to graduate
debt-free and there was no oh i wish i
could have shoulda woulda
you controlled it every step of the way
you hit it off man i love doing this
show with you guys i know we get so
excited
this is good lindsay's with us in uh
cincinnati good afternoon lindsay how
can
christina help hey guys so i'm gonna
like
make you guys even more fired up because
i have a mess
with my student loans so we are in baby
step two obviously
we have been the zeal intense for two
years now be two years in may
okay and we still have hundred and fifty
thousand dollars left
and we've already paid off a hundred
grand oh okay
okay lindsay but it's just it's
exhausting you know it feels like
it consumes every part of me it's
everything we think about it's
everything we talk
about and we are being so impressed
because we want to wait to have kids
until
we're done with our debt which i know
you guys say like that's not exactly
what you recommend
but our minimum payments on our student
loans are 1300 a month
and it's just like we feel i don't know
like
if we don't get to pay it off we we
can't we wouldn't feel right about
bringing that child into that so anyway
i guess i'm just looking for like
motivation or tips or tricks or anything
you guys
can think of to help us stay motivated
and on top of it
so before chrissy talks real quick i
want her to talk because this is her
sweet spot especially for ladies
how much do you all make a year annually
uh close to 150. okay cool go ahead
chrissy all right so here's here's i'm
going to give you a running example
lindsay i love to run i feel like i can
come up with a running example for about
anything
she's a beast depending depending on
the distance that you're running you set
a different pace
so if i'm gonna run one mile i can and
will run that a lot faster than if i set
out to run a marathon which is 26.2
miles
but when you know the distance that you
have to run you set your pace
accordingly now that's not saying
you shouldn't be gazelle intense i love
that about you i think that's amazing
i just want to give you permission to
pace yourself it's a marathon
not a sprint take a deep breath enjoy
little wins along the way
celebrate here and there and you will be
able to last for the long haul but
you're doing great you've got a year
behind you
you can do this and lizzy i'll add this
real quick before we go to break if
you're why does it make you cry
then the price of commitment will you
and your husband should sit down and
really write down what's the why
why are we doing this why are we going
this hard and if that doesn't make you
cry then the processing commitment will
find a way that'll make you emotional
when you get emotional you'll get the
energy to push on to push forward
all right this is the ramsay show
so
[Music]
[Music]
america by now you've probably probably
seen all the tax software
as saying it's free to do your taxes
with the big companies
but news flash for most people it's not
because you have to meet
the right criteria by the time you
realize you don't meet the free
criteria you've put too much time into
it
to start all the way over so you pay up
that's money for the company and here's
the truth
that same company has loads of customer
data and they can sell it
their own privacy statements say so so
if they know
you wound up paying and owing taxes
they've got a green light to send your
information to their business partners
who will then kindly keyword their
kindly
sell you loans and credit cards to help
you pay off your taxes
the tax software guys get a bonus you
get
guess what more debt check this out
they're making a killing off of their
customers
you need something better and i mean
much better that's why we stepped into
the ring
with ramsey smart tax to give you a way
to file your own taxes without paying
more than you expected and without
putting you
at risk to getting more debt i want you
to text the word
tax two three three seven eight nine i'm
say this again
text the word tax three three seven
eight nine seven eight nine
to learn more and get started for free
that's tax
tax two three three seven eight
nine i don't like tax season christie
who does let's be honest i'm just gonna
be real
there are there are a handful of people
that get excited about it i'm not one of
those people i am not one of those
people
uh but you know what maybe got to do
what we got to do
and yeah i think i may be texting the
word tax
uh triple eight eight two five five two
two five christie wright anthony oh here
ramsey personalities taking your phone
calls around money
around life around if you wanna start a
business or i would encourage
any ladies out there uh if you're trying
to figure out how to
balance your life how to figure out how
to find your purpose in life
give us a call actually give kristy a
call and she'll give you the wisdom and
knowledge then i can come in there and
help you get your money right
tad teaming we are i like it i need both
all right sebastian's with us
in tampa florida good afternoon
sebastian how can chrissy and i help
hey how you guys doing a huge fan um
so i have one quick question i have um
one debt it's to my grandparents and
they're really nice about it like
they're not rushing me but it's one of
those things that like
when you sit next to them at dinner it
just food don't taste as good because i
know i owe them that money
um it's three thousand dollars and i
have a thousand dollars
right now safe to pay them back so i
make 15 an hour at my job right now
working 33 hours a week and i'm going to
school
um no student debt i've been cashflowing
that
um i have a side hustle of reselling
shoes
like nikes adidas all that so my main
question was
i want to kind of take it to the next
level with reselling shoes because i've
had like
pretty decent success but to do that i
need to invest in a computer so that i
can run
like softwares like to act like people
so i could pick up more shoes
and the issue with that is a computer
for that
is very specific so i need to build it
and that's 1500
but i know like my profit margin would
be
really like it'd be guaranteed because i
already know how to use most that stuff
i just don't have the computer would it
be wise to
go ahead and invest in the computer
before paying my grandparents off
so that i could like pay them back
faster or should i just keep saving up
as i've been doing
to pay them back how so the thousand
dollars is
is your total savings that's all the
same
i've been saving up for probably the
past like three weeks
and that's what i've gotten so far okay
help me understand this software i'm not
disagreeing i just don't understand it
tell me what you are going to be able to
do
uh with this computer and software that
you can't do right now
on your phone just being scrappy manual
hustling getting it done okay so
what it is it's called box so i bought i
would i
i'm in a cook group which is like i can
rent bots prefer
let's say anywhere from 50 to 240
depending on how good of a software i
want
and what that software will do is on
this computer i could have like
instead of one tab open that is for me
to add a shoe to a cart
i can have 100 to 200 tabs open
and be able to get multiple pairs to
resell
oh so you're trying to get you know
fancy
you're just you're trying to turn these
shoes faster yeah
yeah i have friends that they're already
into this and i see the numbers that
they're able to pull
off from it but i don't have a computer
that's capable of having
that many tabs open and i can run boss
on
all right here's what i want you to do i
want to challenge you on something
sebastian i'm not against
you getting this computer and this
software but i want you to do two things
before you do
the first thing i want you to do is i
want you to if you have a friend
that is truly doing this either ask them
if you can borrow it for a day
for an hour i want you to prove that you
can do this i want you to actually test
the software and prove to yourself that
you can turn this profit that you think
you can before you drop 1500
into it i just want you to test it out
however you go about that whether it's a
friend or
whatever you do i just want you to test
it the second thing if that works and
you're like yeah this is
def i've validated my idea i definitely
can get it i want you to sit down with
your grandparents
tell them your plan and ask their
permission
for you to make this expense with the
intention of you want to pay them off
sooner i want them to feel a part of the
decision
since you're in debt to them just out of
respect for them and for your own
conscience
that you're not sitting down at dinner
feeling like you just bought this
software and feeling even worse about it
and you hid it from them
so i just want you to take a couple
steps and then
the other thing is if you decide to do
it they're good with it you prove your
idea
i want you to set a goal that you are
going to turn
you are going to pay that back to
yourself you're going to make that much
money back
in less than three months i want you i
want you to invest
and that that's why i was um kind of
hesitant instead of just jumping into it
because
i don't want them to think that like oh
he just spent this much money on a
computer and he's not paying us back
like i saw that i set a budget and it's
like
if i do if i live by my budget which
i've been really like been strict to
myself about it
i could have everything paid off to them
in three months and i was like oh maybe
if i can invest into this
i can have it paid back in like two
months all right but like you said
i would have to talk to them first about
it well and but here's the thing
you're in school you're cash flowing
you've got a side hustle you're a driven
guy you're not just sitting around
eating popcorn expecting people to to
make a way for you you're you're trying
and i hear that in your voice and see it
and what you've already done i just want
to make sure when you do this you're up
front with your
grandparents you're clear and prove your
idea that you can do it and then you
hold your feet to the fire to get it
done in two months three months
something like that
and i think you will i think if you do
that that's the right way to go about it
to get it paid off even faster sebastian
let me ask you this what
what was the three thousand dollars for
that your parents loaned you the money
for
so um last year i actually moved out to
go to school in gainesville
um and so i didn't have a job when i
first went there
and so i had to pay my own rent i had to
pay
for food and i made really bad decisions
and i joined the fraternity which i knew
i couldn't afford but i still
did it anyway um i wasn't listening to
you guys obviously
and so now that it's like that i am i'm
like man i really should not have done
that because
that was like 1500 on its own so
luckily my grandparents they helped me
and they're like hey you can pay this
back
whenever you're able to but this is so
that you can like keep going to school
over there
um since then i'm back home ever since
my classes went online for covid
so i don't have to worry about paying
rent or anything like that thank god
so you're you're home you're home doing
online school
yes so that means you haven't you have
access to a computer
i have a computer but it's it's like
eight years old and it's not something i
could run
but i want to know no bro no no no no no
no this this computer won't hold have
that software you can make this work
yeah
you you you can make this work uh
sebastian uh
yeah i thought he didn't have a computer
ao i mean we just had to ask the right
questions here's my thing man
um you know i was agreeing with christy
until you said you had a computer
uh i don't i don't sell shoes you know
same um i don't know the business you
can sell shoes
and you may not be able to sell it as
fast as your friends
but right now i think you have to really
lay down some priorities
you you borrow money from your mom your
parents
so you can join a fraternity you need to
pay them back okay
it's time for you to step up to be a man
so you know what let me do what i got to
do
pay them back and then if you want to
save up to get the computer a better
computer
to sell more shoes then you do that but
i think the first step to being a man
is paying the people use what you've got
i if you've got a computer you've got a
phone use what you've got to do what you
want to do
then you can upgrade it i like that
that's it christy do what you got to do
so you can do one day what you really
want to do i like that
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neil co-hosting with me
today is number one national
best-selling author and host of the
christy wright
show uh the one only christy wright uh
give us a call triple eight eight two
five
five two two five we're taking your
questions here live
on the air and caden is with us in
denver colorado good afternoon caden how
can we help
hey how are you guys doing today thanks
for having me on oh man thank you
so i have uh roughly 120
000 in student loan debt i have
one that's about uh it's a consolidated
like 96 000 loan and then i have
two 5 000 loans and then
to uh just under four thousand dollar
loans
and i have the option to refinance my
uh largest ninety six thousand dollar
loan
to lower my monthly payment by 140 right
now
and i'm on snowball uh the snowballing
step so baby step number two
okay and so i planned on refinancing to
get
that 140 to put towards my smaller loans
okay um but on top of that i'm currently
putting in
eight percent into my 401k is that's
what my company matches okay
and i just didn't know if i should pull
that eight percent out
and put it towards my loans to help me
get out of debt faster
and i do have ten thousand dollars saved
in my savings as well okay
and so i was just looking for some
guidance and you know how to maneuver
and use what i have to
you know get those rolling in the right
direction you called the right show man
christy and i are going to walk you
through this and help you out as much as
possible
um so let's let's let's rewind uh talk
to me about the refi
uh two quick questions for you and you
may or may not know them if you do not
know these
what i want you to do is go and find out
here's the very first question
um is there a cost the
whoever's refining your student loans
are they charging you a fee
to do the processing to do it do you
know if they are
they are not okay cool so that's the
first step i like that number two
is the interest rate at least a good
full percent below
where you are now it's just under two
percent
just under i'm loving it i'm loving it
so yes we are refining
okay so what we're definitely gonna do
is gonna refi then i like how you said
it because we're gonna take that extra
money that we got back and not just the
extra money you got back which about 140
bucks
we're gonna go out there and we're gonna
get a job okay we're gonna get an extra
job
and we're going to attack it so yes
you're going to line up
your student loans from smallest to
largest now let me answer this question
so make sure that we're teaching the
correct stuff do you have any other debt
outside of your student loans right now
um i have no credit card debt
but i do have twenty thousand dollars in
a loan payment an auto loan
okay cool so this is what we're going to
do walk this down so you're gonna put 4k
that's that's number one you have two of
those you're going to
4k there 4k there then you have two 5k
you're going to line that up
right behind the 4ks then you're going
to put the 20k
in there okay then you're going to put
the 96k of student loans
so that's how you're going to line it up
so you're going to take that 96 uh
whatever you refi any extra money the
first one goes towards the first four
you can make minimum payments on all of
them but then you're gonna do that now
you got ten thousand dollars
you're not you're not gonna like what
i'm about to say all right but i'm gonna
tell you how it is because you caught
into the ramsay show
and just on on this day you got christy
and anthony and so we keep it raw with
you
you're gonna take nine thousand dollars
of that
you're gonna knock out the both the four
thousand dollar loans
and you're gonna put a thousand of that
towards the 5k so now you're down
to 4k left um and then 20 000 was your
auto loan did a 96 thousand dollars
then you're gonna aggressively attack it
so you follow what i'm saying
yes okay so you're to go ahead and spend
a 9k
on your debt you're going to stop
investing at eight percent
how much are you what does that come out
to for you how much about what
200 bucks that's uh 540 bucks extra a
month
oh yeah i could be getting yes yes yes
stop it right now as soon as you hang up
from us
uh email hr tell them hey we need to
stop this we need to pause this
uh and don't pull nothing out of your
401k
okay all we simply want to do is pause
we still want the money to grow but
we're going to take that 540 plus the
extra 140 and we're going to put this
towards your debt
and if you aggressively do this man and
if you get an extra job on the side
you can definitely definitely get out of
this i was saying about two two and a
half years
um i'm gonna let chrissy talk to you but
then stay on the line i'ma have kelly
send you a copy of my
destroy your student loan debt a book
that's free on christy and myself
actually free on me because this is my
my book chrissy's just shaking her head
thank you i appreciate that yeah yeah
read the book it'll take you an hour to
read it but
uh any other insight christy yeah here's
the thing i just want to call out
because it may be
tempting when you get into this caden to
list your debts from smallest to largest
just like anthony told you but then
you're going to have a thought you're
like wait a minute
wait a minute but what about the
interest rate shouldn't i attack
the highest interest rate first and
people start getting into the numbers
and they start getting into the math of
it and they start to try to well i
should do it different because my
situation is special
and i'm different and i got a different
set of baby steps let me tell you
something
if we were thinking about math we never
would have got ourselves into this
situation to begin with this is more
about
motivation than math and when you do
what anthony just told you to do and you
knock out those small debts it's going
to give you a
burst of motivation and momentum and
progress
and you're going to get that much more
fired up you may go get two or three
jobs
to start to attack that next debt
because you can start to see the
progress of you knocking them out and i
just want to encourage you follow the
plan as we've laid it out
don't get distracted by the interest
rate numbers if that's a different order
for you
you want to stay focused on smallest to
largest because it's more about
motivation
than math i love it katie is with us in
minneapolis good afternoon katie how can
christy and i help
katie hi hey hey hey
great to be talking to you guys
absolutely thanks for calling how can we
help
i have a quick question about the uh
every dollar budget
philosophy okay and cash flow yeah
so i've been using the every dollar
budget app for a while and the last few
days of the month i go in and i sort of
do a true up on the budget
see if we have any money left over make
the debt payments we have a sinking fund
for the house and move the money into
the savings and all of that
now for peace of mind we keep about 650
in the savings account just in case i
forgot something major during the month
so at the beginning of march we had a
situation where march 1st rolls around
and the state takes 500 out for the
taxes we owe them and daycare takes 300
out for our weekly amount now both of
those items are in the march budget so
that's not a problem
except that our first paycheck doesn't
hit until the seventh
so for those five days i've got a little
bit of a cash flow issue and
just wondering how you'd recommend
accounting for that in every dollar
how many months have you been doing in
every dollar budget what was that
how many months have you been doing in
every dollar budget
um
[Applause]
off and on i got off of it a little bit
around the holidays with a lot of other
stuff going on and i kind of
fell off the wagon but i've been doing
it for a solid three or four months now
okay okay yeah yeah yeah go ahead jump
into that so here's the thing uh
now you sound like it was a surprise
because i mean your daycare is not a
surprise
uh was his taxes a surprise to you the
timing of it was we knew what was coming
out like i said i had it in the march
budget
i didn't know exactly when they were
going to draw it out so
the timing on it being exactly march 1st
was like oh
rats yeah yeah so here here's what i do
because you know
both chrissy and i income or fluctuates
one month we can have a great month next
month we can
you know not have a great month but what
i do with inside of my every dollar
budget
what i do is if i know i owe something
for an example my mortgage is due in the
first
um i actually set that up for that to be
the last
payment of the last month so for an
example if i say if i get paid on the
15th of the
previous month well i'm taking it from
that check
that's going to pay anything that's in
the beginning of the month
and so for you what i would do is make
sure that you know and do research
call the people whoever's pulling from
your account say hey when are you
pulling this
you have to be very detailed no one just
says hey we don't know when we're going
to pull it we're just going to pull it
whenever no everyone has a due date
everyone knows when when they want the
money and so you need to identify that
moving
forward everyone has a due date everyone
says payment needs to be in on this
particular day
so that's what i would recommend for you
on an every dollar budget is
make sure stuff like that for taxes call
them hey when are you pulling this money
out of the account
yeah yeah and i think as you learn those
rhythms it will just get easier just
like your point is like
our main commission check comes on the
15th so if we didn't
plan right then the first through the
15th if you literally did it first of
the month or 30th of the month
you wouldn't have as much money for what
you need the first half you just have to
get in that rhythm where that money is
there before
and it may be changing your auto draft
payments a little bit differently you
just you just gotta learn and adjust
absolutely chrissy it's a great hour
it's fun this is really fun america
thank you all for rocking with us
thank you james kelly and uh yo at the
end of the day
this is the ramsey show god bless you
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money my name is
anthony o'neil host of the popular
youtube and podcast show the table with
anthony o'neill
and co-hosting with me today is number
one national bestselling author
and the host of the christy wright show
the one and only christy
wright and we are excited today you guys
because we get to talk to you america
we get to talk to you about your life
your money
relationship goals uh family goals
money goals and if you are a young lady
or woman out there and you're trying to
figure out how to balance life
and how to find your purpose or even
start a business
um the expert is in the building today
and that is christy wright and we would
love for you to give us a call
we have just maybe one phone line open
so give us a call at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five again that number is
triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
chris i feel like going straight to the
phone lines let's do it let's
do it uh brandon is with us in austin
texas good afternoon brandon how can
christy and i help
brandon how are you guys doing doing
good man
how can we help bro i have
had a question so we have my wife and i
have
house paid off no student loans no
credit card
the only debt we have are two vehicles
okay we have the cash in savings but
vehicles are one of those things i hate
spending money on because they
immediately the day after you pay them
off are already worth less
than what you paid for uh should we
continue to finance those
or pay them off okay let's talk talk to
me about them um how much do you own
both the cars
i have about fifty thousand on both of
them between the two of them
okay so fifty thousand dollars in cars
how much do you have in your savings
right now
um we've got about sixty five thousand
dollars in the savings
okay so we got about 65k in savings all
right
and this is your only debt so no student
loans
no credit cards nothing just fifty
thousand dollars in
uh car loans correct correct
cool great let me answer this question
why do you want to keep paying
interest on something on a depreciating
asset
so i mean the interest is low enough
that it's always been one of those
things that i
felt better to save the cash than to
invest into a vehicle that would be
worth
less the next day if you were to get
back or if something were to happen
so even if your interest is at one
percent two percent you do understand
that you're paying more money on the car
that you're saying is depreciating
so wouldn't you rather save yourself
money in the long run
uh and pay it off
yeah i guess that makes sense yeah i
mean it doesn't change the numbers the
interest was low
yeah you know i mean it doesn't change
the numbers if you own it or if it's
financed the value of the car is going
to be the value of the car
the value of the car is not dictated by
how it's financed yeah the va
you're just kind of playing this game
with yourself right you know what i mean
so it's like
let's just pay it off you've got the
money paid off and also man
brandon it's gonna feel so good to be
completely debt-free like you're
right there you're one click away yeah
from being completely debt-free
including your house that's insane
and you've got 15 grand left over in
savings like you're gonna be in a sweet
spot i think it's just that last it's
almost like a security blanket it's like
oh i'm so comfortable i'm used to this i
feel good about it
we gotta we gotta go if you're gonna
grow outside of this
you're gonna have to get a little bit
uncomfortable from your old ways of
doing things but it's going to be
so worth it i tell people all the time
brandon the voice of debt is always the
voice of regret
and whenever you pay that off you're
going to feel more free than you've ever
felt in your life then you can just keep
adding to that savings and you can do
anything you want to
absolutely it's a good feeling brandon
hang up the phone from us man go pay off
your car
you got it right now do it
all right in two minutes brandon's about
to be totally different exactly and if
you do it within the next two minutes
call us back let's do a debt free stream
on their hair
oh that'd be fun pay it off man pay it
off
all right you got the money that's
awesome that's funny alex is with us
in where's house oh he's in chicago good
afternoon alex how can christy and i
help
hi there thanks for taking my call yeah
how can we help
so i'm 23 right now um i graduate in may
from school
i've got around 19 000 dollars in
student dot
um in 2017 i had like thirty thousand
dollars fall into my lap i didn't know
what to do with that so i just invested
it i didn't want to touch it
um so right now it's at fifty thousand
dollars i don't know what i wanna do
with that like i wanna you know have it
grow as much as it can but i don't know
if i wanna tackle my student debt
um because of covid the there's no
interest
on any of my debt until september which
is awesome yeah so i don't know if now
is the time to pay off my student loans
or if i should
i mean i've been listening to your show
all day i might as well just pay it off
but i do want to hear what you have to
say yeah but let's talk about this this
is a little bit different it's a little
different
yes it's a little different you're fifty
thousand dollars what is it invested in
is it invested in retirement or is it
just invested in just regular
mutual funds or single stocks mutual
funds
so mutual funds right now it's not
covered by retirement accounts like a
roth ira
a traditional ira or anything like that
right correct
okay cool so and you have nineteen
thousand dollars in student loans
yes okay yeah so because it's not
invested i want to make sure this is
very clear
unto the people who are listening
because it's not invested into a
retirement long-term account
i would definitely say take out 20 000
and pay off your student loans then take
the other thousand dollars and
at your age bracket go ahead and invest
that into a retirement account go ahead
and put into a
a roth ira traditional ira but before
you do any kind of flipping over there i
would want you to talk to a smart vessel
pro
that can walk you through the process
and educate you on why
and how to do this but i will go in
ahead because there
is not covered with a traditional
or a roth or retirement plan go ahead
and pull it all out so
not all of it uh 20 000 so you can pay
off your student loans
and then get on the phone with a smart
vessel pro who can walk you through how
to invest
the other 30 000 to cover you long term
so you can get more interest
um you can set yourself up to win so i
would definitely go that route
but you're graduating in may outside of
the 19k in student loans do you have any
other debt
i don't that would be it so no car knows
no you don't have a credit card for
emergencies no
that's awesome well done i'm just making
sure because you you sound like a smart
smart individual so i just want to make
sure that we have a clear understanding
here that we don't do that let me let me
hear you say that
uh we don't do that repeat after me i
don't do that
i don't do that there you go i like that
you say that say that one more time say
it louder say i don't do that
yeah i don't do that you're so bossy
today
listen the only other thing i would add
to this conversation uh
is that you want to start saving up
you're at a transitional stage in life
so whether you are going to be moving
moving out
buying a house at some point start
you're going to be debt-free
and you got a little bit of investment
start saving up to have a good emergency
fund and transition
uh money for these life transitions
coming up no this is this is
that's so so so good christy one of the
key things i tell young people
graduating
uh college especially in the midst of a
pandemic right now of what we're facing
it's focused on the things that you can
control and do not sweat over the things
you can't control
you know and as of right now uh this
individual
had the income to go ahead and pay off
the student loans invest this thing
properly
get a good job start investing some more
uh by the time alex turns
40 50 years old i mean that we're
looking at millions
you know and so this is very important
focus on the things you can control
and don't sweat over the things you
can't control this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost sharing ministry
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neill co-hosting with me
today
is christy wright number one national
bestselling author and host of the
christy wright show
and we are taking your phone calls today
triple eight eight two five
five two two five again the number here
is triple eight eight two five
five two two five and we're talking
about a little bit of everything so if
you just have a general question about
life um give us a call we love talking
about that we love talking about money
but we also love talking about other
things
as well uh but uh i'm excited what's on
your heart
you know here's the thing we've been
hearing a lot of calls in the last hour
or so
and a lot of them around debt which is
pretty typical that's what a lot of
americans are struggling with
and you may be listening to this right
now and you might be feeling like well
that's just a way of life
i'm always going to have this debt i'm
always going to have this payment it's
normal i'm used to it
you may feel like you're never going to
actually have extra money
for those goals these things that you
want to do if this sounds like you
it is time for a new way of thinking
so here's the deal you have to believe
that you can get rid of debt and take
control of your money because you can
but if you don't believe it you won't
try
and here's the good news we help
millions of americans do just that
and it won't take nearly as long as you
think it will with ramsay
plus we're going to kick you off with 90
days of guided help so you can put more
of your money
back into your bank account translation
you get to keep your hard-earned money
money you'll learn the practical ways to
get small consistent wins that add to
big results and better habits and that
means that you get to where
be where you want to be faster and
debt-free spending your money without
worry this year you can make more
progress on your debt and savings than
you ever
have before get ramsey plus
and start living the life you want
faster to reset your money and start
ramsay plus for
free free trial go to daveramsey.com
that's daveramsey.com it's a free trial
y'all listen this
is the plan you need to win and we know
it because we've seen millions
of americans do it you can too that's
dave ramsey.com
daveramsey.com catherine's with us
in kentucky good afternoon catherine how
can christy and i help
hey thank you guys so much for taking my
call i appreciate it yeah
um i guess my question is my husband and
i are
doing decently well financially we're
actually starting on the baby steps and
we'll be through baby step four
recording my calculations in about 16
months
however i'm thinking about my parents
future which i know just sounds a little
silly but they're in their mid-60s i'm
27.
they're not in the greatest health one
is still pretty able-bodied and has been
struggling finding employment
throughout the pandemic because she lost
her job
my father is on partial disability
disability right now
and trying to continue working for a few
more years but
unfortunately they spent their entire
retirement on their divorce five years
ago
and they didn't have much to begin with
how would you suggest
my brother and i and my husband trying
to help
figure out what to do for their futures
in case their health fails and they're
unable to take care of themselves and
need more assistance
well i got a question before ao jumps in
on this one because
catherine this is a while it's a
financial question it's also an
incredibly personal question
it's a values question it's a family
question i'm curious what are some of
the conversations y'all have already
been having because i'm guessing you're
having them
what are some ideas you're tossing
around is there a is there a tug or
something that you're starting to kind
of
wrestle through as a starting point for
me and anthony to help you
kind of guide you in the right direction
i'm curious what the conversations are
looking like
already between you guys well the
conversations between my brother and i
have been
just filled with concern his financial
situation is
finally starting to look up he actually
filed for bankruptcy a couple of years
ago himself
so he's not you know hasn't been in the
best financial situation but he's also
starting to work through the baby steps
so um our conversations have been kind
of like well we're just trying to help
ourselves at this point
get to a better situation and if we can
help them how can we help them but
you know our values are you take care of
family but
i think our family has a history of
helping family out to the point of
hurting each other unintentionally
you know i helped pay mortgage in high
school which is fine
but my parents have borrowed money from
me in the past taken it out of my
account i finally took them off my
accounts right before i got married
you know so it was bailing one person
out to get themselves in trouble and
i've always been the person to bail out
my entire family
because they keep feeling each other out
so it's you know
i guess i've always had this feeling of
i have to help them because i'm in the
best financial
situation of the four of us
so i don't know i don't know where to go
from here
and you know this is always a hard
conversation to have
because i hear in your heart that you
love your parents that you want to be
there for your parents
but then i also hear in your heart i
need to be here for my family
you know i need i need to do the right
thing for my family
and and so i i want to say this this is
not dave ramsey saying it this is not
christy wright saying this is me
i'm going to put my family first my wife
my kids first their household yeah i'm
going to put our household first i want
to make sure
that i am not jeopardizing my home
because i am responsible for my home
my wife would be responsible for her
home
if if we think about someone else's home
before hours
we're just setting ourselves up to fail
to have
arguments that are unnecessary to have
things that are unhealthy in our homes
and so for me i'm going to suggest
again i'm not a relationship expert um
sit down with your husband
it's our bae can we is there anything
that we can do
and if and if y'all two come up together
and say baby no there's nothing we can
do
there is nothing wrong with that um
because right now the priority is home
chrissy you're married you know you and
your husband i'm pretty sure have had
these kind of conversations in the past
with family what would you say yeah it's
interesting i would say that it's a
to me it's a two-part thing catherine so
i totally agree with what you said
anthony of sit down with your husband
and what i would say is because you're a
baby step four you're close to baby step
four
you're in a stable position financially
which is awesome
so what i would say is it would look
like a conversation like this you and
your husband sit down and you say
what amount of money if any or what
amount of blessing whether it's we're
going to buy groceries or
what does that look like what amount do
we feel good about
giving to bless them with no strings
attached
no expectations it's a gift it's not a
debt to be repaid
and we're going to bless them at the
same time
i want to just encourage you catherine
to remind yourself
regularly that you are not responsible
for your parents poor financial choices
and if you feel responsibility which is
unhealthy and inaccurate then you are
going to lean toward what anthony's
saying which is giving more than you're
able to give and
even enabling their behavior to continue
to make poor financial disorders you're
going to fund
poor financial choices at your own
family's expense so i would just say
you want to have a conversation with
your spouse and say do we want to
bless them and that's what it is it's
like out of the abundance you bless and
take care of family not to
uh jeopardize your own family but just
as what you're saying you're heart of we
take care of family this is how you're
gonna do it
but with a limit it's planned it's
strategic it's intentional you're on the
same page with your spouse and it's with
no strings attached knowing that if they
completely blow it and they don't have
dinner that weekend
that is not your responsibility does
that make sense it's hard though
i'm making it sound very easy it's not
easy
at all but i think it gives you some
guard rails
some structure to the thought process
which is highly emotional highly
personal
but it helps you move forward with some
type of
um structure around your thinking so the
emotions don't
get you know run away with you yeah and
then after you had that conversation
like chrissy said and y'all set those
guard rails what i would do is go have a
conversation with you and your husband
with your parents and say hey mom dad
this is what
we have in mind what we can do to help
you all but make sure that they're a
part of the conversation and then also
jump on the phone with one of our smart
vessel pros so we can sit down and say
okay hey
how can we help them win with the
finances they have coming in right now
so we're going to give them a little bit
if we can as a family
uh but then they have some kind of
income coming in right now
what can they do with that income to set
them up to win
in the future and it take less stress
or a lot more stress off of you your
family
and your siblings so um catherine i hear
it in your heart
you know um that you love your parents
and
i'm praying for you christie's praying
for you um and i believe that god is
gonna give you all the wisdom and the
knowledge to make the right decision for
you your family and your parents but
just make sure that you don't put
your personal household at risk this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neill ramsay personality
and joining
with me is actually joined with me is
chrissy wright also ramsey personality
number one national bestselling author
and
host of the popular um youtube and
podcast so you can check her out every
tuesday
on youtube and anywhere else in the
podcast called the christy wright
show where she um helps you break
through what's holding you back create a
life
you're proud of and build confidence in
yourself
and the god who created you uh chris
let's talk about your book though real
quick before we go to the blinds.com
question
um your balance we've got our uh
yeah living through 40 days to get back
to you we're talking about so many
things today but this has been really
cool because we
even this morning i had a time with all
the women here at ramsey solutions
we wrapped up the last 40 days together
i'm going to kick off another one on
april 6th though you know i've talked
about this a 40 is such a
biblical number and so this devotional
walks you through
who god is who you are where you are and
where you're going and as you walk
through that
these different sections you really not
only get back to who you are but you get
back to who god created you to be
and it's been really powerful to hear
the testimonies and the success stories
and the reviews coming in of how god
spoke to someone exactly what they
needed to hear
on that day uh through that so if you're
interested in that that's living true
40 days to get back to you it's my new
devotional and you can get that at
ramseysolutions.com or wherever
books are sold absolutely before we get
to the blinds.com go follow her on
twitter and on instagram
because if she does it she's going to do
it live on instagram so go to
christybewrite christybewrite
ladies be a part of that um because i
promise you
when christy gets to preaching she gets
to preach it so you want to be there
so what's our blinds.com question of the
day yes so blinds.com 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color they
make your blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month
you save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best deal
rules and restrictions apply all right
today's question comes from courtney in
new jersey
here's what she says i own a small
speech therapy practice in new jersey
i'm currently the sole provider for the
practice but have an ever growing wait
list
of individuals looking for services i'm
considering hiring a part-time employee
to assist with the growth
i'm wondering how much you recommend
having saved in a business savings
account to ensure that i'm still able to
pay an employee
what they're due even in the event of
low income
months okay this is great and what i
love about this question is this is
actually really helpful for anyone with
a small business
whether you're a sole provider or not a
solopreneur or not
so we always recommend that you have
three to six months of business expenses
in a savings account that is accessible
just like we recommend
on the personal side this is called
retained earnings this is going to help
you if your computer crashes your
vehicle has a problem you need new tires
on your delivery vehicle
same concept for business three to six
months
of business expenses that would help you
cash flow the payroll
in the low months if that happened now i
will um
encourage you to take this a step
further courtney because you're talking
about your first hire
anthony your first tire is your hardest
because it feels scary and risky are
they going to do as good of a job as i
do in my business and that type of thing
so i want to give you three things to
think about if you are a solopreneur and
you're considering hiring your first
person
number one you are ready to hire your
first person when you are
maxed out now you get to define maxed
out
maxed out for you might be 10 hours a
week if you're a stay-at-home mom you're
busy with your kids you've got other
things this is a side business you don't
want to give more than 10 hours a week
that's fine
maxed out for you might be 80 hours a
week you get to decide what your
definition of maxed out is but when you
are maxed out by your definition
you might be ready to hire someone
number two when you actually
have the money to pay them not you hope
you'll have the money when they get
there
because guess what it's going to take
them a couple months in most businesses
to actually bring in an roi a return in
your investment
some of them they're just learning the
ropes they're learning what you need to
do they're training
they're not necessarily producing money
for your revenue for your business on
that first day or even first month or
two months which means you need that
savings account we talked about
to be able to pay them because they're
still going to expect to get paid
even though they have not produced
revenue for your business yet but the
third one is probably the most important
anthony and this is really important for
people
especially in the side gig generation
people that are solopreneurs they've got
home-based businesses that type of thing
i want you to think about if you want
to lead another person no one asks this
question
they think well the demand is there i
need to grow my business i'm going to
hire people but here's what happens when
you hire people
you are by definition a leader
which means you're responsible for
training that person hiring that person
leading that person paying that person
dealing with every aspect
of leadership now if you want to lead
cool
you got the money cool you're maxed out
cool you're ready to hire someone go
ahead and do that
but if you don't want to lead if you
just love doing your thing
it's just you and your business you can
do what you want you're not responsible
for other people
that's fine too might be time to raise
your prices and figure out other ways to
scale and grow
outside of hiring hiring is not the only
way for you to grow for example courtney
in new jersey i'm just going to throw
out an
idea for you let's say that you're one
of those people that doesn't want to
hire but you want to grow you can raise
your prices
you're making more money money per
client you could even create a course an
online digital course
that helps parents do speech therapy
with their kids
at home and then that course is mailbox
money for you in the background boom
you've scaled your business beyond
yourself in the dollar per hour rate and
you never hired
a person to do it i just want you guys
to get creative and really think about
is leading right for you if it is
awesome you can hire
and learn how to be a good leader for
that person or people but if it's not
just
know there's not a ceiling on your
business you have opportunities to grow
scale and make more money
without hiring christie
you won't point you you you you good at
what you did
here's your steps one two three steps
here we go i love it christy's good
all right let's go out to um fort
lauderdale and talk to jared jared good
afternoon how can christy and i help
hey how you guys doing doing good man
thanks for calling in all right
um okay so kind of a layered story here
but
in essence um my mother actually passed
about two or three months ago i'm sorry
and
thank you guys um so i'm left with a
house
uh my brother and i live here we don't
own it
there's still a mortgage on it um
i however am debt free and i plan on
moving very soon
i'd like to move to colorado and
i'm basically looking at a small nest
egg
there were a couple in inheritance we
got
and i'm looking at what do i do with the
house
so you know if we sell it
we're let's say we're both in terms of
the equity if i did my math
we're both gonna end up with about sixty
thousand each
so if i add that to my small nest
necessity i'm probably looking somewhere
around 100 000.
but my thing is i don't have a big
income so i'm just wondering
what i should do because some people
have told me you know try to buy your
house
buy your half of the house from him make
it a um investment property or do i go
buy a house somewhere else
what do you guys spend well let's let's
let's break this down how old are you
bro
i'm 22. how old is your brother he's 24.
24. okay do both of you all want to stay
in that house long term
no no he wants to move to colorado yeah
so does he want to stay in the house
no he does not cool sell the house man
definitely sell the house um
and and do that asap you don't want to
be managing a rental property from
colorado yeah i mean that's just i guess
that's fair
yeah yeah yeah so that that's easy that
that's the easy question
let's talk about your life you're saying
you're not making a lot of money right
now
what do you do for a living i just work
in a warehouse
okay uh well that's a job you working
full 40 hours a week
uh no i'm working part time i had
stopped working full time because i
wanted to take
a test that i had gone to school for but
i'm honestly kind of
leaning away from it and just i don't
really care for
the subject anymore i wanted to be a
nurse and that's not really for me
anymore
okay all right all right so here's the
thing right now
sell the house that's game plan number
one do you have any debt
real quickly yes or no uh no you're
debt-free okay cool
go ahead and get you a fully funded
emergency fund which it sounds like you
already have
and then i'll take that money and figure
out okay get you a job figure out what
you want to do as far as in life
you know what do you want to do where
you want to go yeah if you want to be a
nurse cool great
cash flow that you got the money to do
that if you want to be a carpenter you
got the money to go to carpenter school
the next big thing for you is to sit
down and ask yourself
what do i want to do where am i going
with my life then once you identify that
then backtrack and figure out what is
the plan what is the process what are
the steps
i need to take to go there and to do
that
but sell the house get the money next up
figure out what you want to do with your
life thanks so much for calling a man
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neill ramsey's personality
joining me is christy wright number one
national bestselling author and also
ramsey personality we're taking your
phone calls here
live on air triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five going
back to the phone lines christy we have
jackson
uh in new york city good afternoon
jackson how can christy and i help
good afternoon guys how are you good
what's up
hi um so i
do football card selling on ebay and i
know i sound young i'm 13.
oh awesome yeah so
i'm about to acquire five thousand
dollars due to
um cards that i'm currently shipping out
and i was wondering what i should do
with that money
jackson this is so cool this is this is
the probably the best call
all day i like this thank you all right
so talk to me man um
five thousand dollars so what you're
going to get here pretty soon because
you're working hard you're making some
money so that's great
um what do you see where do you see
yourself going in the future do you see
yourself going to college or not going
to college
my parents want me to but i don't know i
i probably will end up going but i don't
want to
i mean i i already invested in the stock
market
um and i've been thinking about um going
into real estate investing
okay and also
um investing in like companies like um
like eventually like venture capital
living okay
okay jackson i am loving this i'm loving
it too i'm loving it too real quick then
i'll let kristy come in here and give
you some wisdom man because she's the
she's the queen of uh starting
businesses and stuff like that
i um i want to advise you to
listen to your parents wisdom as far as
in school
okay i'm not saying that you have to go
to school but what i am saying is
listen to your parents wisdom and
guidance so this five thousand dollars
that you have
i would not invest it what i would do is
i would save it i would put it into a
savings account
keep making money keep putting money in
that account so this way
if you and your parents key word there
you
and your parents decide that college is
the best route
you can come to the table and say mom
dad hey i have fifteen thousand dollars
now
that can go towards my college
experience then let's say
um you decide to go to real estate
school you and your parents
then you can spend that money to pay for
real estate school and then
invest the rest you know so what i would
say is i wouldn't worry about making
more money right now i would park this
money in the savings account
until you can figure out what you are
going to do you're 13 years old
i'm pretty sure you're not driving i can
put like a
you know a million dollars on it right
now you're not driving yet
and so you may need to use this money to
purchase a car
and so what i always recommend young
people is don't think about how you can
make
a lot of money fast right now no how can
you set yourself
up to win and be successful in the
season you're in
right now you're 13. you still have a
new card coming that you're going to
want to purchase here soon
you have prom coming up you're going to
want to go to and you have
college those are the three big things
that in your age bracket
you have coming up and i want you to
actually take some ownership and some of
that
if you purchase the first card say mom
dad i'll put 2 500
in if you all can put 2 500 in that
would speak volumes and you'll be
driving the car that you actually helped
purchase
and you'll be a ball it in in the young
people's uh
words i love it the one thing i would
encourage you jackson is
uh there are very few people in life
that know what they want to do for the
rest of their life at a young age now
you have them
you have those people that oh i remember
being six years old and i wanted to
you know be an artist and then they
become an artist that's the
exception not the rule the vast majority
of people change their mind about what
they want to do
about 15 times i have i never in a
million years
imagined that i would be doing what i'm
doing and i love what i'm doing so much
more than even the dreams that i had
when i was young and the reason i say
that jackson is because you're going to
figure out what you want to do
with your life with your money with your
job with your college with your time
with your career by trying stuff that's
how you're going to figure it out
you're not just going to have this
perfect plan most likely you're going to
figure it out by experimenting and what
i love about you jackson is you're
already doing that
you're selling football cards right now
you're making some money you've got some
options you might try
a different business when you're 15 that
involves you driving
maybe it's something else entirely but
you're going to figure out what you love
and what you want to do more of by
trying some stuff and because you're
trying
so early and you're experimenting and
you're starting to benefit the
rewards of your hard work even
financially you're going to figure that
out a lot sooner
and because of that you're going to have
a lot more fun and make a lot more money
but i just want to encourage you to give
yourself permission
to try some stuff and you're going to
have this in your savings account and
you're going to keep trying little
uh you know side gigs or turn those into
small businesses even before you get
college age
and you're going to know a lot more by
the end so don't feel the pressure to
have it all figured out
but keep doing what you're doing you're
doing awesome absolutely jackson stay on
the line i'm half kelly
uh kelly's gonna send you a copy of my
teen entrepreneur toolbox kit you're
already killing it right now
but i want to help you make a lot of
money during this season and so i'm
gonna send you this kit
on me and on christy so you can learn
how to expand your business and make you
know
another 10 15 000 uh this year
by doing it right so stay on the line
kelly will get that taken care of for
you
and we're going to go out to dallas
texas and talk to lane good afternoon
how can christie and i help
christie ao thank you so much for taking
my call got a problem
i want to jot down i got some numbers
here for you my wife and i were both 24
been married for about eight months here
we're working on baby step
3b currently have six months in our
emergency fund
we're able to save about 4 000 a month
towards our house down payment
we currently have 85 000 in savings for
house down payment and we're looking to
buy a house in the 300 to 400 000
range here in the north dallas area
the market is very hot and houses that
are at a
appraised tax value of 300 000 are
typically selling in the date of two
days for
three hundred and sixty thousand so my
question to you two
with my wife and i already being
pre-approved at a 2.375 rate on a
15-year
fixed mortgage what would be the best
route for us to go
over the next three to six months in
purchasing our first home
to not overpay simply based on the
extreme demand we're seeing here in
dallas right now
yeah so you already have your 20 down
because in between 300 and 400 looking
at about 60 to 70 thousand dollars
uh in a down payment so you already have
a 20 so you two are already on on the go
you all are making the right moves
uh the good thing here with an opi over
here yeah so so here there's no pmi you
said in texas
no the two of us aren't with you oh okay
yeah i was about to say yeah yeah yeah i
was about to say yeah
there's pmi everywhere brother uh but i
get what you're saying i get what you're
saying yeah i love that i love that
here's how you win you have to find
a real good realtor okay
you you need to find you a real good
real estate agent who can help you
uh make the right decisions on this
journey who can fight for you
and make sure that you do not overpay
because you've already done the
the good stuff when you're in you're
debt-free you already have the twenty
percent uh to put down on the home
you already know your budget in between
three and four hundred thousand dollars
that's great
now you take all that information you go
over to a real estate agent
and you tell them hey here's our budget
this is the mass we can do but if the
house is only worth 300 000
we are not paying 360. if the house is
only worth 400 we're not paying 410.
go find us a house that we like that is
in our budget and they will do that and
you have to trust them
and give them the opportunity to fight
for you yeah lane i would say we are
actually experiencing something so
similar right now in the nashville
market it is one of the top places in
the country to move
from california from all over with the
pandemic and
those different regulations and it is
absolutely killing
our real estate market people are
overpaying crazy prices here in
nashville
so i i do agree with anthony that a real
estate agent is going to help advise you
especially because it's your first home
a couple other options i just want to
throw out there and they may advise you
on this
as well depending on what the market
looks like it may be something where you
wait
a little bit you're not in a bad
position you are saving
a crazy amount of money every month you
have a great down payment
don't make a short term rushed wrong
decision just because you're excited to
buy a house and you have the money and
overpay just like anthony said
the other thing is ask your agent and
talk to your spouse
about this is there something a little
bit rare that you guys could live with
a different area that's not as hot uh
something about this house that isn't as
popular where you could
be more competitive for a more accurate
price that other people wouldn't be as
competitive for
but hey at the end of the day you are
winning yeah we are proud of you
six months in an emergency account
eighty thousand dollars already saved to
put down in the house
man come on let's go that's what
we are here to do to help people win
like that
it's been a great hour christy james
kelly this is the ramsey show
guys this is kelly associate producer
for the ramsay show did you know that
over 16 million people listen to the
ramsey show every week
and a lot of those people listed on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
daveramsey.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and
your money my name is anthony o'neill
host of the popular youtube and podcast
show the table
with anthony o'neil and co-hosting with
me today
is number one national best-selling
author and host of
the christy wright show the one and only
christy wright
both of us are ramsey personalities and
we are excited because we get to spend
this hour with you america
and we love talking about all things
especially money
uh but if you want to talk about
relationships if you want to talk about
how to find
balance if you want to talk about your
purpose if you want to talk about god
if you want to talk about money um if
you want to talk about how to start a
business
um give us a call chrissy's here she can
help out
i'm gonna talk about money she's gonna
talk about life and money
uh triple eight eight two five five two
two five triple eight eight two five
five is the number to call in um and we
would love to take your phone call
let's go to the phone lines uh chris
josh is with us
in uh phoenix i love that city good
afternoon josh how
can christy and i help hey anthony great
to talk with you guys so
i have a very cute peculiar uh situation
that me and my wife are in so we've paid
off 150
000 in student loan debt in the past
five years all right um yeah that's
great
we're we're definitely focused um so we
have one debt
left um and it's 140 000
um my in-laws took out a home equity
loan for this hundred and forty thousand
and it was 140
000 and my wife's private student loans
that they consolidated to make the
payment cheaper
okay um so our situation is
they have said multiple times that they
will forgive the loan eventually
it has not happened yet we who is
currently paying a monthly payment
uh my wife's parents okay
and uh they've said that they'll forgive
it eventually there's no
specific timetable or anything we pay
the payment on the mortgage directly
ourselves and pay a couple extra
payments
as far as our situation in my mind i
want to put the extra money from our
snowball towards
our home mortgage or our 529 plan for my
son
where my wife wants to put any extra
money towards that loan that her parents
gave us
even though they said that they're going
to forgive it eventually so
we just don't know what to do one thing
i want to call out that
you are experiencing josh and this is
the reason we tell family not to loan
family money
is because it it tilts the room
it tilts the table it now there is an
imbalance
in the relationship and because of this
financial debt
and so what i don't like about this
question
is they have something over you and even
the fact that they're telling you
they're going to forgive it bothers me
because it's this reminder that they
have something over you they're holding
something over even if they don't
intentionally mean that maliciously they
may not at all they may be
wonderful people and they may really
plan to forgive it but the dynamics of
this
need to change i'm going to let anthony
jump in here first but i just want to
call out
we need to fix this situation whether we
fix it through a conversation
and a deadline or we fix it through
repayment or some combination of both
but i don't like this in between where
you guys have this held over your head i
don't like it at all
yeah yeah i'm right there with you
christy um you know josh i i want to
have the conversation with with in-laws
hey we need clarity okay because we're
trying to move forward but we have this
hanging over our head
when you say forgive it uh when okay
when is the cut-off date do we need to
be paying up until
go ahead yeah so their house is paid off
right now they live in san diego and in
the next couple years they're going to
sell it which theoretically when they
sell it that loan will be
paid off all right guys so
that that's the big uh question now
yeah yeah uh so you're in a tough
situation
because you're waiting on your parents
to sell to sell their house which will
eventually sell
uh pay off the heloc and
you're trying to figure out what to do
but they expect you to pay between now
and then right
yeah that's what i'm saying yeah we've
been paying
monthly and then we do like one or two
extra payments a month
just to lower you know just pay off the
principal as much as we can
yeah i would say if they're sorry i keep
jumping in here
i would say if they are expecting you to
pay between now and when and if they
ever forgive
then you're going to keep paying between
now and then regardless here's what i
would do for my own peace of mind josh
i would plan to pay the whole thing off
as if they never sell it absolutely i
would just plan on that
expect to and then if and when they sell
it and they forgive it or they set you
whatever
then it's like this wonderful surprise
not something you're waiting around on
you know tapping your heels going oh how
many more months do i have to pay this
you owe it right so just expect that you
have to pay it until the whole thing's
paid off and if you don't
then it's a wonderful surprise and bonus
but for your own peace of mind
i would i would try to pay it and expect
to and knock it out as if you're you're
gonna have to pay it off yeah no i i i
we're gonna leave it right there i i
really do agree with you on that part i
mean that was a good answer
i really do it's just a weird dynamic
because it's like maybe but it get it
goes back to that power control
because what if they don't what if they
change their mind they don't want to
sell and they're like oh dang it i was
like planning on you know no just for
your own peace of mind piece of mind you
owe this
yeah plan to pay it yeah if you don't
have to that's just a fun surprise
absolutely i mean you signed up for the
debt
your parents helped you out they said
hey you're going to pay us back
pay us back and then for me i'm not even
getting comfortable i'm trying i'm
sitting out my wife
i'm saying hey look how do we pay this
thing off in the next year year and a
half
well because if you because the question
he asked should we put more toward our
house
if you were to do that with that money
it's as if that debt's not there but it
is
yes it is there yeah and it's no
different than any other type of debt in
the fact that you owe it
so just you need to attack it like you
would if you were in baby step two
because you
are in a weird way pay that off before
you put extra on your house your house
you get to
after your debt free and you're not
debt-free yet so ah i love it
well you guys here at ram solutions we
want to transform so many lives that
disruption spreads like wildfire
across our country imagine a world where
it is weird to have student loan instead
of everyone assuming
that's the only way to get an education
imagine a world where the majority of
people pay cash for their cars
imagine a world where credit cards are
the cigarette
of the financial industry imagine being
a part of
causing that level of disruption with
the work you
do every day at ramsey solutions that's
why we have
a thousand people at our company working
together to create digital products and
services to help people
transform their lives with the goal of
disruption
disrupting the toxic money culture that
exists in america today
if you want to join us on that crusade
we're currently on the hunt
for many software engineers with
expertise in
ruby on rails java c-sharp and front-end
technologies or if you're a
ux designer seo and content marketing
specialist
we would love to talk with you like
seriously asap
so to find out about all the available
jobs by texting
make sure the text work that matters
again that is work
that matters to 33789
takes work that matters all one word
work that matters to 33789
to find out about all our opening
opportunities
and i'll slide this in there too because
i got the mic i'm also hiring
for a video producer so not only
if you want to do that but if you want
to help me reach young people yes
text the word work that matters to three
three seven eight nine
and come join an amazing team over here
at random solutions
and your boy anthony this is the ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neil ramsey personality
joining with me is another ramsay
personality number one national
bestselling author
kristy wright host of the christy wright
show and together
we're taking your phone calls and
answering your questions i'm around
money around life
around relationships around um business
business around ladies development
personal development i mean we're just
having a blast
and so we have about one line that just
opened up so give us a call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five uh triple eight eight
two five
five two two five and chrissy and i
would love to talk to you we're we're a
little bit nicer than dave sometimes we
can be
just as mean but you know we won't hang
up on you well i'll just lie
let's go out to california and talk to
adam good afternoon adam how can
christine and i help hi anthony christie
thanks for taking my call
let me give you guys a little bit of
background really quick my wife and i
are debt free we're big dave ramsey
advocates
we're now in the market to purchase a
house okay
and it's similar to your previous caller
we have about two hundred thousand
dollars saved up
wow house we're looking around a million
dollars at the price point
for us um but we we're looking we're
putting it down
offers in within four days there's 42
offers and the last home we
put an offer and it went over two
hundred thousand dollars in asking price
and so we recently just sold a house in
texas
and lost 70 000 so i have a little bit
of
angst by buying a house and a bad time
yeah
and so i just wanted to get your guys
take with the interest rates i think
they just increased about half a percent
in the last
month which is giving us a little bit
more buying power
okay should we buy now and just say this
is the reality of the market
or should we hold off if you guys know
any trends around the interest rates or
the markets
that we can buy at the right time versus
overspending and then the market
flattening out because of supply
increasing where are you living now
we live in laguna beach orange county
and you own your home
we're renting an apartment right now
okay
and we cash flow about 100 000
um cash that we can save a year so are
you all in the rush to purchase today
adam or do you just we're not in a rush
from
a living perspective it's just knowing
that
the as soon as a house hits the market
today
it has 20 offers within three days
and the interest rates keep climbing and
the asking prices keep climbing
because everyone from the like la area
is moving to orange county because they
don't have to work in the city anymore
okay okay here's my suggestion i i'm not
going to
i'm not going to rush purchasing a home
right now because you're you're saving a
lot of money
and sooner or later i think patience
good things come
to those who are patient who
wait and i think right now what i will
continue doing is keep your eye on the
market
do not go over your budget do not pay
more
for a house if it's only worth a million
don't pay 1.2 don't pay 1.1 wait because
you're in you're in orange county
california so you to get a good house
out there
yeah you're going to be right up there
in the uh 800 to about one 1.2 million
dollars to get the kind of house that
you it sounds like you you and your wife
want
but i i would wait man i mean if it
takes you another year
maybe two years to find the right house
that's okay well and the other thing if
you think about it from a numbers
perspective i think you said you're able
to save a hundred thousand dollars a
year
which is incredible so when you think
about this let's say you decide to wait
until the market levels out which it
should at some point i
i'm not an expert in real estate an
agent can help you kind of know what's
going on
you're not regressing in your financial
goals by waiting
you're still making progress financially
in your goals by saving a hundred
thousand dollars a year
and then you're able to buy a house at a
price that's more appropriate for what
it's going to be appraised at
if you try to rush and you overpay then
you
are losing that money for right now and
there's absolutely no reason to you're
not in a rush so keep saving your money
wait and unless you if you found
something in between there that's going
to go at
its regular price or it's rare it's
different or you get there first or
whatever
cool you're ready to jump on it you've
got the money but don't rush and overpay
and just throw that money away
absolutely i agree i agree
kelton is with us in memphis tennessee
good afternoon kelton
uh i love your name by the way um how
can we help thank you hi
so i'm uh 19. um up until last
month i was pretty much debt free i had
a small car loan
uh i was on full ride scholarship at u
of m
okay and uh basically i was involved
in the situation and it left me
i'm charged with three felonies um
and now i have eight thousand dollars
worth of debt
and i have upcoming debt and i lost my
job because
of this and i'm kicked out of school
yeah i owe my apartment
a whole lot of money yeah because that's
where the situation happened it
um i don't even know where to go like
how to start paying off all this debt i
mean
i have a job now i got another job and
it's paying like 300
a week okay but it's not even enough to
make it dance
yeah that's twelve hundred dollars a
month i did yeah
i said that's twelve hundred dollars a
month that's that's that's not yeah
that's not uh that's money but it's not
enough money
for what you need to do no not at all
and i'm i don't have much work
experience i had a job paying 19 hours
but
it was through my school basically okay
without putting too much of your
personal information on on
uh live on air are these felonies
preventing you from getting
a a better job oh yes sir
they're um they're violent someone
there's
aggravated assault aggravated assault
okay cool have you gotten with an
attorney to figure out what is the game
plan to get these off your record in the
future
oh yes sir i hired a really good
attorney with everything that i had
um and i sold my car okay um
yeah so he's working with you to to
eventually get it off your record right
yes sir i'm still looking at um
potentially some time but it's hard to
say
you know it it just happened not too
long ago i have a hearing another
hearing next week that's going to give
me a better idea of what's going to
happen
it's going to be the future but each
felony carries like 8 to 12 years
eight to 12 years ouch here's my thing
man i i
and um one i want to thank you for
calling into the show yeah
um and uh i want you to know that
i don't know you killed him but i'm
gonna be praying for you because
your future um uh could change
dramatically um for
probably the first time that i've been
on the ramsay show i would say right now
i'm not concerned about your debt
i'm concerned about you i'm concerned
about your mental health
i'm concerned about um
you as an individual i i want to i would
encourage you
continue working continue doing what
you're doing
but right now it sounds like you need to
get around other
men of older men who can speak into your
life
um who you can just draw from cry on
um just really be honest with and so
that
they can help you develop yourself into
a better man heck and i'm gonna be real
with you i have that
um i am developing myself into a better
man
um and certainly i don't want you to
feel like you're alone out here
uh but right now i'm not too concerned
kelton with your debt
i'm concerned with you yeah yeah the the
one thing i would say that may give you
some source
of comfort or control kelton and this is
super tactical but it's just an
option for you um like first of all i
cannot recommend enough
you getting around um whether it's
getting plugged into a church or
community of men that can become around
you through this season of life you need
uh people to lean on um but one of the
things i heard in your question
was a lot of overwhelm there's this
money in this money and then my
apartment and then these fees it just
sound it feels overwhelming
and and it is but one of the things you
can do to reduce overwhelm as tactical
as is is just list out what those are
not just like well there's money here
and i'm not sure and what it's like okay
i owe my apartment
ten thousand dollars io court fees of
this amount of money
you're not sure when you're going to
tackle it that's okay but i think
sometimes when you see something when
you get it out of your head and onto
paper and you can see you're like okay
i can tackle this i don't know how and
when in what timeline but when i can see
it i can do it and that will just give
you some
source of control over your situation
it's not this unknown that's
haunting you you can see it set it aside
get the community around you
and then you can work on a plan to
tackle it yeah uh
on the line i'm gonna have kelly get uh
get your contact information i'm gonna
have my producer reach out to you
i wanna speak into your life i wanna
talk to you i'm gonna bring you on to my
show
and just spend 30 minutes with you man
and just walk through your stuff and
speak into your life brother because i
think we all need brothers to do that so
stay on the line kelly get your
information
my people reach out to you this is the
ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thanks for listening you guys you're
listening to the ramsay show christy
wright and myself anthony o'neil ramsey
personalities
taking your phone calls we have this
segment and one more segment
left we have about one phone line open
so give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we would love to talk to you over
these next two segments
um and joe's with us in missouri um good
afternoon how can we help
yeah how are you doing doing good man
what's going on
so i had a question me and my fiance got
laid off in colorado
and i moved out to colorado because my
ex-wife and moved out there with my kids
to help raise them but then she moved
away again
okay so we got a really good job offer
in southeast missouri
where i'm from my family all lives down
here so we moved down here
and my mom's like well you should just
move out on the farm so they've got
18 acres close by
that has water and electric it used to
have a house but it's dilapidated now
it's really really dangerous to be
around so it's kind of
a big liability for my mom
so we got to talking about i'm like yeah
we could probably build a house out
there in the next couple of years
but then they backtracked and they won't
put it in our name they want to put it
in a trust in me and my brother and
sister's name
and i don't think that's a very wise
idea from my standpoint
so then she gave the idea of splitting
it up in three
six acre sections but it goes up a
holler
and two of the sections would literally
be a hill you can't climb up
so you're splitting property into three
different areas to pay taxes on as well
and then i'd have a section down the
middle you know where i could actually
live
and i offered to buy it out from her for
fifty four thousand and only appraised
for 34
but i really want to live there and she
declined that because she said that
wouldn't be fair to my brother and
sister
so i'm looking for some advice joe it
sounds like to me and correct me if i'm
wrong here it sounds like to me i hear
it in your voice
this is a bad plan and you know this is
a bad plan
like i hear it in the question that this
is already decided in your mind it's a
bad plan
and you're right because what's
interesting is anytime i'm hosting
this show and we get a call about should
i do this
in relation to my parents my parents
land my parents house my parents
whatever
the question we always ask is would you
do this if it wasn't your parents
would you want to build a house in a
dilapidated house on this property
overpay by 24 000 all these scenarios
that you're telling me
would you want to do that if it wasn't
your parents no
no you wouldn't want to do that so we're
not going to the next question is
then they want to put it in a trust is
that going to put liability on me if
somebody gets hurt out there because
they want me to clean the whole thing up
my brother and sister are not interested
nobody's been out there really in 10
years
they just go out there and throw out a
couch here and there so it's trashed on
top of the house being dilapidated
and there's neighbor kids on
four-wheelers riding through there all
the time and somebody's gonna get hurt
and if i'm gonna trust with it i'm
either gonna have to clean it up or take
that liability
and i don't think that's wise either no
i don't even understand why they're
putting
in a trust with such a small piece of
property either sorry
right no no you're right here i'll tell
you um straight up joe i don't know the
details
from the legal implications of a trust
but i would imagine
that responsibility this is my hunch
here
the responsibility cannot be put on you
without your consent you cannot be
responsible for property
liability all these things without your
consent even if it's your parent so
there would have to be some consent on
your part
you need to probably talk with an
attorney and you definitely need to talk
to your mom
like what are you doing what are you
doing this is not my responsibility
i feel like that you need to have more
of a voice in this discussion
and and really have discernment for what
is right for you
and your family apart from your parents
what is right for you where do you want
to live where do you want to build what
kind of house that type of thing
and and enter into the discussion with
that in mind
not making all these compromises and
going along with bad plans just because
mom came up with it and benefits her and
it sucks for you i don't like this i
don't like any of these plans for you i
don't like that go ahead what i think
would benefit her the most she's been
dead up to her eyeballs
she had four mortgages at one time they
actually took one out on that
piece of property to buy the current
household and while they had two
mortgages on another piece of property
they weren't living in
that they were upside down on so they
couldn't sell it so she's 60 years old
my dad's 70. back in 2008 my dad
convinced her to cash out her 401k so
she's sitting on nothing
with all this debt and that's partly why
i offered more for the house to help her
in the long run but i think she should
just
pay me to clean it up and sell it and
pay off her house
to try to get to you know to a better
position well here's the thing man you
called and asked us for advice for you
not for right right
right you know and i i agree with
christy this is not a good deal
leave it alone leave it alone uh if your
mom puts it into a trust
okay uh you are not held liable for any
of the the issues that come up right now
okay once you are awarded what's what's
inside the trust then you will be
but as of right now you will not be held
live before that okay
uh i was just going out there man and
just move on with your life
say mom thank you mom i love you um i
tried to work with you in this area but
i see right now you're just not ready to
do it
and that's fine you know your mom
doesn't have to do what what she doesn't
want to do
she's a grown person it be wise for me
to not even be involved in the trust
because it
it'll be every weekend for nine months
for me to get this cleaned up out there
yes and i don't want the liability i
would not take any liability right now
the other thing i would say joe is in
and i know it's your mom and i'm talking
about your mama here
on on the air but like she doesn't have
a great track record financially with
financial decisions
so we're going to look at that track
record you love your mom you're never
going to not love your mom
and you're never going to not be your
son but when we look at the financial
track record
it's not good decision so we're not
going to enter into more financial
agreements with mom
because of the track record and because
it's a bad plan but just like anthony
said she can do what she wants to do i
want to remind you you can too
you get to decide when and how and where
and if at all you participate in
anything with this land
you do not have to do anything you are
not obligated to do anything
you get to make a decision as a grown
man what is right for you and you do not
have to do anything so just remember
that in all the discussions
so good good good good good amanda's
with us in baton rouge good afternoon
amanda how can christie and i help
hello thanks for taking my call
yeah sure what's going on um well i'm in
a column
right now uh i mean it's not anything
major but um
i'm currently i'm out of debt the only
debt i have is my mortgage
so i'm very happy about that i have no
credit card just pay off my car
note yes saving money i have money in my
savings
how much but uh 12 over 12 000.
okay and i'm trying to i'll try to build
it up more
but the problem i'm having i guess is
with the coronavirus and stuff that's
going on economy and
you know you get worried about your
career and stuff like that i'm getting
kind of burned out
with my career okay um i've been doing
the same career for 25 years
and i'm always interested in science so
i was thinking about changing my career
and i contacted someone
it's an associate's degree and i would
be making about the same amount of pay
but the problem is i just found out the
tuition cost is 37
000 uh for just under two years and i
really don't want to take a student loan
out
because i'm doing fine right now and i
want to save more money
and contribute even more in my roth
because i'm 47 right now and
i'm trying to max out my contributions
and everything so i'm just wondering how
should i go about this i don't want to
have a loan for this school or should i
just keep doing what i'm doing
and just save as much as i can so what's
real quickly
real quickly before we go to break
what's your dream career field if you
could do anything right now
what would that be um
i would say i mean definitely something
science uh what i was looking into was
you know
working the the degree i'm looking at is
working in the operating room
okay or uh even forensics or something
like that
science based because that's what i'm
strong in okay i got you
uh one of our good friends ken coleman
um says you really
you really need to identify what you
want to do so right now we really can't
give you the advice that you really need
because
you don't really know exactly what you
want to do
so here's the best piece of advice i can
give you
um today is tomorrow
afternoon i think you're right around 11
o'clock central time i want to get on
youtube
and i want you to call in to the ken
coleman show and i want you to ask this
exact same question to ken coleman
who is our career expert he is america's
number one career expert
and he can walk you through this process
so know the student loans
but i think we need to figure out what's
your sweet spot what are you passionate
about
once we can identify that which can will
help you do that
then we can figure out what's the best
path to do that so call in tomorrow
to the king coleman show go to
kingcombingshow.com or go to youtube
and he will help you out i promise this
is ramsay show
[Music]
today's scripture and quote comes from
isaiah chapter 43 verses
18 through 19 and it says remember not
the former things nor consider the
things of
old behold i am doing a new thing now it
springs forth
do you not perceive it i will make a way
in the wilderness
and rivers in the desert winston
churchill once said we
shape our dwellings and afterwards our
dwellings
shape us i love winston churchill
he's got so many great quotes i just i
just i just love them
i love them welcome back to the ram to
show you guys my name is anthony o'neil
joining me
uh here in the studio is christy wright
ramsey personalities
host of the christy wright show and host
of the table with anthony o'neil it's
been an amazing hour rocking out with
you all
we have about maybe six more minutes so
we can maybe squeeze in one more phone
call triple eight eight two five
five two two five give us a call but
right now
alyssa is in denver colorado good
afternoon alyssa how can christy and i
help
hello hi christy so i am currently an
outside sales professional for a science
and graphics franchise
and i have the opportunity to purchase
the franchise that i started my career
at
um and it's very early the conversations
with the corporate office are just now
getting started
um but i am in baby step two
it's always been a dream of mine to own
my own franchise but i'm only
i'm 33 i expected i'd be closer to 50
but the opportunity is here
and i imagine it'll be about
somewhere between 400 and 600 000 to buy
the franchise
do they um have a franchise model or are
they starting it with you
no no no this is an existing a very
existing
franchise i'm curious you said you've
always wanted to own your own franchise
tell me a little bit more about that
well i've always wanted to own this
franchise well
by always i mean i've been in a career
for seven years
and but i really fell in love with it i
am passionate about what it is that i
do from an outside sales professional
perspective
and i would like to think that i would
be a good business owner because i
i do care so much about um the purpose
but um i am a little nervous about being
a business owner
right i mean there's definitely some
things that i would need to work on
personally i'm a little
tough and i don't want to scare anybody
but um
you know scary any of my potential
employees but i
really love the organization and the
business
and i know everything about it apart
from like
you know the business side of it of like
taxes and the important stuff
um but i and the opportunity is here
and i know that i've always i've been
working my way towards owning this
franchise
a franchise within the organization um
but
now the one in my hometown is available
for sale
and now i kind of it's kind of fallen
into my lap i don't want to make a bad
choice
yeah um of being too emotional about
this specific location
in my hometown yeah so here's what's
interesting um
the reason that people typically want to
get a franchise
is because they want to run their own
business and
they feel like a franchise is a business
in a box
and so there's something appealing about
the fact that they are going to give you
all the details the logos the the you
know the
the formula for it you don't have to
think about that for yourself the
downside to this though
is it's a very expensive way
to start a business and run a business
own a business when you could start
something literally on the side yourself
tomorrow
with zero startup now you're a little
bit different than the average person i
talk to that's interested in franchise
because you love this particular
business what i'm
curious is how long would it take you to
make back that money
in it over and above what you're making
now working for them
and when you run those numbers i think
you'll be shocked at how long it will
take you
to make that back because that is a very
expensive
cost of a franchise and we're never
going to recommend you take out debt
which means you'd have to cash flow it
and so i'm not trying to be discouraging
i'm just trying to be discouraging
i'm just i'm not trying to discourage
you alissa in business because you know
i'm so
pro-business but here's what i want
here's what i want to encourage you
how can you pursue some aspect of what
you want to do whether that's move
up in the organization you're in in a
more leadership role
without the cost of this half a million
dollars startup
or is there something is there some
other aspect of running a business that
you would want to do on your own
separate from this business that has the
same type of impact or the same type of
services product whatever i just want
you to explore it i think that you're on
to something here
that you see something in yourself you
want to pursue and i think that is good
i just want you to explore other ways to
pursue it
outside of paying a half a million
dollars which i'm guessing you don't
have
that's yes that's correct i do not have
it so
so so just when you say it fell in your
lap lots of bad ideas can fall in your
lap lots of bad opportunities can fall
on your lap but we think oh because it
fell in my lap it must mean it's right
for me
listen debt is not right for you making
a bad decision is never right for you
bad opportunities are not right for you
but the good news is you love what you
do you work for a good company
that's not going to change tomorrow if
you don't decide to franchise this
you can still keep doing what you do
loving it
making good money maybe even coming up
with an advancement
uh path with your leader some some type
of management maybe there's some
advancement there
and or exploring other business
opportunities that you start on the side
and by the way you
own all of it you have full creative
rights to make it whatever you want it
to be because
the other aspect of a franchise that
most people don't consider
is you're still working for someone you
quote unquote own it
but if you start a subway franchise
you're not coming up with a different
subway logo
you're doing it the way that subway runs
it's going to be laid out how they lay
out
it's the the upside of a business in a
box but the downside of business in a
box and so i just want you to explore
all your options i think it's awesome
that you happen to love this company
i don't want you to pay a half a million
dollars to do what you're already doing
because it's going to take you a long
time
to make that back and that's just not a
good plan but i do want to encourage you
to explore other ways
to lean into that thing that makes you
light up right now in a different way
that doesn't cost a half a million
dollars
stay online i'll have kelly send you my
book business boutique
and that will help you not only explore
what those opportunities are
but even test them out experiment a
little bit maybe you start something on
the side maybe you get to
lean into those gifts and you learn more
about yourself in the process through
reading that so stay on the line kelly
can get that for you
love it jen is with us in billings good
afternoon jen how can chrissy and i help
hi anthony hi christy um hey i'm 45
almost 46 my husband's 42. okay we have
approximately 1800 left
in consumer debt okay but here comes a
but i have
over a hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt
and my husband has about 40 000 in
student loan debt
i'm thinking i don't know if this is the
right way is once we pay off the last of
our consumer debt
is kind of put baby step two on hold
build up our three to six month
emergency fund and then then
aggressively attack or
excuse me aggressively attack our
student loan debt what's your household
income
between the two of us about 70 000 a
year oh my goodness
um what what what did y'all get your
degree in
okay hundred i said 111 000 is for me
and it's a master's in human services
administration i was
25 26 and a single mom when i went to
college
so i pretty much put it you know i was
living off of student loan debt as a
single mom
okay all right cool and what about your
husband he's his
in um network network technician
technician he does stuff with computers
okay cool um so real quickly because
we're about to end the show here um
no your your philosophy is off uh
jen i'm sorry um i want you and and
a lot of people say this consumer debt
consumer debt
is including your student loans okay um
anything outside of the consumer that
would be a mortgage and so you got to
work the baby steps jen
i mean i'm just going to be i wasn't
sure i wanted to make sure on that one
and i understand i mean you all make you
all make decent income the average
household income in america is running
between 58 and 68 thousand dollars
depending on what side of america you're
on so you guys are actually a little bit
above that
but you are sitting with over a hundred
thousand dollars on student loans and i
know that looks like a mountain
but chrissy teaches something real good
um about just really taking it one step
at a time one bite at a time
and just aggressively going after it uh
i would definitely sit down get the
budget and honestly you two need to come
up with a
bigger source of income yeah you gotta
get your income up yeah gotta get gotta
get it up you know
get some side jobs uh and i get it you
guys are
in your 40s but that's still young um
but right now
right now you need to get your shovel
bigger yeah to make more progress
otherwise it's gonna feel like that
mountain
you're not making any progress yeah get
your income up start a side business
side hustles
extra jobs and you'll start to see more
progress that'll motivate you
to stick with it you got this you can do
it i'm so sorry that you're going
through that
oh man well chrissy it's been fun hi
great job today
real fun i want to thank our thank our
producer james charles and kelly daniel
in america do not forget that the
caliber of all of our futures will be
determined by the decisions we
make today in america y'all made one of
the best ones today by listening to
christy and i
right here on the ramsay show
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
you